tre reporter david khalifa et il est
toujours dans le cortège de ceux décidés
traditionnels du 1er mai david vous êtes
donc avec nous est ce qu'on peut dire
que la tension est légèrement redescendu
à huy la tension est largement retombé
même ici en tête du cortège de ce défilé
du 1er mai qui seront doucement mais
sûrement jusqu'à la place de la nation
le cortège initial de cette
manifestation est de ce défilé du 1er
mai lorsqu'il s'est passé c'est que en
tête du cortège syndical et une
constitution de black blocks c'est comme
ça qu'on peut les appeler son est
intervenue et ont lancé des projectiles
du mobilier urbain vers les forces de
l'ordre casser une banque ayant incendié
du mobilier urbain également en réponse
les forces de l'ordre sont intervenues à
très vite avec des jets de gaz
lacrymogène et maya également de
quelques arrestations
et puis pendant à peu près une trentaine
de minutes les affrontements se sont à
répéter au niveau 2 de ceux du haut
niveau du boulevard voltaire où je me
trouvais tout à l'heure et
tranquillement plus de manière plus
détendue le cortège a plu repartira plus
que le calme est revenu ne pas obliger
ne pas oublier effectivement les
objectifs principaux de ce défilé du 1er
mai des revendications sociales restée
muette depuis un an puisque
souvenez-vous il n'avait pas pu a défilé
il y a un an à cause du coc vide à 19
l'objectif était donc de rappeler les
revendications sociales questions
sociales sont toujours d'actualité alors
que la crise sanitaire n'a fait que
creuser si vous voulez ces inégalités
sociales je vous propose d'écouter
philippe martinez secrétaire général et
fédéral de la cgt
si les revendications sur l'emploi sur
les questions de salaires et puis contre
la réforme de l'assurance chômage je
crois qu'il ya une palette de
revendications importantes qui sont pas
nouvelles d'ailleurs le retrait de la
réforme
le retrait de la réforme c'est une
réforme injuste c'est une réforme qui va
pénaliser encore plus ceux qui sont déjà
dans une grande précarité et on sait
bien
par expérience de ces années passées que
c'est pas en s'attaquant aux chômeurs
qu'on crée de l'emploi
bien au contraire il faut de la
protection il faut des garanties pour
ceux qui cherchent du boulot pas les
enfoncer dans la misère l'idée
évidemment est une convergence des
luttes
aujourd'hui pour ce défilé à du 1er mai
qui arrive qui touche en tout cas sa
destination finale la place de la nation
comme vous le disait le calme est revenu
et le cortège est encadré par un
important dispositif de sécurité
renforcé au niveau de l'endroit où
l'incendié s'est déclaré
je le rappelle environ 5000 policiers
ont été déployés pour encadrer ce
cortège parisien et plusieurs
arrestations ont eu lieu au sein du
cortège également en tout cas le la
manifestation bientôt toucher à sa fin
pour arriver à la place de la nation
avec toujours les mêmes revendications
sociales
évidemment et est l'essence même de ce
1er mai manifester pour les travailleurs